what's going on reject nation it's Greg
outta here and it's John here so today
we're going to do a special video we're
calling this video great trailers for
terrible films oh yeah we did we took
awhile to put this list together that we
kind of brainstormed a little bit we
like two trailers in mind and then
patreon one of our perks is we do a
Google hangout there are three people in
that chat that day Garrett hood Andrew
Hayes and totally jumbled and we told
them like we have this video idea to do
great trailers or terrible films that we
were all kind of brainstorming and then
after that John and I sat down and we
thought about what to make a list so
here we are well here we go let's kick
it off with number five number five all
right join you suggestin number five so
what is it
it is the trailer for The Hills Have
Eyes - Hills Have Eyes part 2 the sequel
for 2007 I saw this from the theaters
and the Hills Have Eyes part two and
this one is absolutely horrendous hell
is the earth in theaters it was
agonizing it was just an agonizing
experience it's clumsy it's disgusting
and the characters are annoyed
it's everything wrong with a horror
thriller it's nothing like what this
teaser trailer represented the reason
this is number five because yeah we're
aware this is a teaser trailer yeah but
it's nothing like what this teaser
trailer hints at I mean like what are
the vibes you get when you watch this
teaser trick it's just eerie and it's
like being in hell this is like a kind
of a nice little Pete it's a short film
to me like I watch this just
periodically sometimes because it's it's
just a perfect little horror movie in
and of itself and like that the little
twist where the camera falls over is so
similar but it's it's so horrifying
well you get this vibe that it's going
to be a slow paced tension thriller and
we'll have artistic Tiger style and
direction to it when it's nothing like
that at all this was strictly made for
the trailer yeah this is not a scene
that's actually in the movie
one minute trailer is exceptionally
cooler than any second weight of the
actual film because the movie only like
the thing about the first rimae Alex
like it's magical because it is really
ugly and mean but there's something
inside of it that makes it more than
that you know yeah it's really gripping
and it's really also well assembled and
this one second one just loses the
nuances and becomes ugly this is
creative enough that it makes you go oh
wow whoever made this must be making it
pretty cool yeah with a lot of yell like
you said it's even the way just at the
end the crooked point of view becomes it
particularly dissolves into the tiny
card and it be clogged a new image out
of the old image and it doesn't look
weird at all the shot also looks like
it's just a shot until the Yanks you're
like oh crap were in POV and that makes
it creepy and underlying eerie the whole
time like it's a little story alright so
number four on the list I believe was
suggested as I never totally jumbled or
Andrew Hayes who specifically suggested
this when I remember one one of them
said it my record lives through yeah
yeah one of them said it I immediately
went dad has to go on the list because
right when they said they should I
remembered seeing this trailer and
thinking this movie looks awesome that I
remember the movie and I doubted you but
then when we memorized it a trailer like
yeah it was - meaning again and now we
just watch it again right now if four
Transformers Revenge of the Fallen the
second Transformers movie which is
hailed by many to be the worst
transformers movie of them all I don't
remember it fondly very well at all now
we can spend all day talking that about
revenge of the phone we won't take the
time to do that here what makes this
trailer so good it tail its trailer
number one but it's essentially a teaser
trailer in the smartest way it'd look
like a two minute trailer can see
seconds into the trailer before that it
looks like a disaster film but in a good
way look like a good role in every movie
oh yeah because it looks like it like we
don't see anything that's too huge yeah
like your buildings toppling over it's
like these places that are a little
smaller and a little closer to the
ground and it feels like that could
maybe fit into the real world somehow
exactly we don't know it's a
Transformers movie until a 1-point you
see this shot where this guy's in is a
like apartment or something and then a
transformer goes through and you're like
this is a transformer movie yeah and
then felt like transformer stuff starts
happening and it gets you excited to see
the transformers
but the main difference of this trailer
does is compared to the movie is this
true makes it look like the movie takes
its time has tension build it actually
looks scary it's actually gripping yeah
it's a gripping trail I get chills when
I watch this trailer yeah I think what
you mean like it is really compelling
and it does just it shows everybody's
reaction to happening and this kind of
unexplainable even with Shia LaBeouf
like you but you say you stay whatever
he says you run hide yeah hey where I am
going on a star together you know stop
you don't hide your what gives you I'm
saying we're all going together that
moment right there is intense if my
guess is going to be personable and darn
it and it feels like the Transformers
are up against a major threat right now
it actually hooks you in and I remember
watching this trailer going I think they
might have improved the movie yeah I I
believed it for a second watching it
just now I don't Transformers movies
have a reputation for have a really good
trailers for really bad films but this
one specifically makes it look like a
great blockbuster bit this one trailer
by the way all the links on the
description box there go see a trail is
over talked about here's trailers
yeah study marketing yeah this one has
that is attention to it and it feels
suspenseful and scary and the most
important part is even though it's a
trailer it makes it look like the film
will take its time and not be so
scattershot edited like how that movie
was yeah it's I don't know it's imposing
instead of annoying yeah when I saw
revenge of the Fallen it was almost like
eating cotton candy for a really long
time it's just not Griffon all edited
trailers everything so number three on
our list is Quantum of Solace and so as
you can see we're going in order of most
disappointing now the reason why this
movie was exceptionally disappointing
was because it's a follow-up to see no
write out who goes like the triumphant
Redeemer
James Bond with a new look at a new vibe
you know going more realistic showing I
got a double O status and something like
remaking a lot more personnel and one of
our buff - yeah when this trailer came
out it was really cool and White House
trailer again I'm like this makes the
movie look really good at least makes it
look gripping and intelligible yeah
like a Bond movie that's the biggest
thing about it was the way this trailers
edited its edited to the music so well
and they chose all just the right little
seconds of the movie to make it look
like a cohesive film that is shot well
it has great action and bond humor like
revenge of the Fallen - this has that
quality where it makes it look like it
takes more time where I remember that
movie feeling like it was edit and head
under way out and man what it happened
it's probably the biggest takeaway I got
when I watch this trailer was the action
scenes look more bearable on the trailer
than the actual movie because in the
actual movie it got a kicks off with his
crazy car chase and then bond shooting
and then they even had that really cool
shot in the trailer where they fall off
a boy and then go again blam yeah that
it looks so cool in the trailer there
when he's falling from the rope and he
cheating is caught on by his ankle then
he shoots the gun it was a double of
seven credits they took the best moments
of the actions parts that you can
invisibly tell what's going on it made
it look like the a Kadir is going to be
really cool and they took moments where
they went slice together looks like Bond
has a sense of humor it looks like you
got a good bond romance going on and it
was exciting cuz it was the first time
where it was going to be a direct sequel
to a Bond movie yeah that had up for the
last one left exactly have any cook I'm
having a storyline that's following
through from the last serial bond and
then because they did that it actually
made the movie worse yeah yeah and then
you throw up your hands and you're like
what how am I going to know the exciting
a conclusion to Casino Royale again I
want a quantum of solace from this movie
yeah and then Emile over here had a good
feelin it look where he had all the
right Bond ingredients it was paying up
and work as seen alrea left off and but
it was just a really well executed
trailer yeah well yeah yeah yeah yeah
cuz this trailer feels like a movie and
the movie to me felt like just being hit
in the head with a brick a lot number
two number two on this list number one
number two we thought it out for a while
and this was that bummer man and this is
the savior is over when all the great
trailers were dropping and all
all the not-self intros at the gun room
we don't like great trailers were very
dissonant and this one was a major one
development yeah cuz this trailer sold
me like I would have sold my body do
this yeah
Terminator Salvation oh my goodness this
was a cirno point so much about this
sure I mean first off when you heard
Arnold wasn't going to be in it because
he was governor at the time yeah it was
like well then why make it when you see
the trailer like oh you're going to do
this in a further direct yeah I get you
yeah it has it's like apocalyptic Ngata
max vibe with a lot more Android
technology it looks like an epic war
film about the resistance versing the
machines and like like having an actual
fight like yeah is there matched up it
looks like emotionally intense and yeah
they took moments that don't play so
effective in the movie like when he's
firing the gas got in yelling and when
he's shouting into the wrong dog state
of course
like in hindsight this is a store yes
but it looks like elliptic war emotional
epic totally which is franking V is not
a looks visually appealing which the
movie is not which you can't I feel like
you can't I know you have to get as many
people to see your movie as possible but
the Terminator series is already proven
to us twice at least that they can
achieve that yeah
and so when you promise that a trailer
like this this rail has everything you
want it's like Oh
Christian Bale like he's hot right now
but it looks like he's really invested
in this yeah they don't offer the Dark
Knight on this yeah yeah and it's like
McGee's stepping up you talking a real
good game a real movie now okay yeah and
and this is a series where maybe he
could and they were talking that game
they were like meh no no no no we're
gonna make this about the ward about the
characters and about all that stuff and
then like two weeks before the release
the word changed and uh and movies not
focused it's really bad and also
Christian Bale's
one of my biggest complaints about the
movie was Christian Bale's voice in the
film how he sent every line the same it
didn't seem like a real voice the entire
time but in the trailer it works so well
his voice yeah what was he realizes
that's the only way he talks and then
you learn what happened to your
brokenness oh yeah
and even looks like there might be a
heavy like romantic element with John
with John Connor and Bryce's Howard
character yeah well there's that whole
thing with Marcus Wright with with there
were they blow one of the most
interesting pieces of the movie yeah and
it's a great moment like it was it was a
moment that when I saw it in the trailer
I was like oh wow I want to see this now
like that was the clincher moment and it
gives just the whole thing like the
whole thing away the whole it's what
they keep giving away twists and
Terminator trailer and the Trent Reznor
soundtrack over this trailer the whole
role annoying and beautiful choice of
music and I mean finally used in the
movie ever which could have benefited
from it yeah like do ya trick if David
Fincher want to make it server different
render that would be an alright idea
because the yeah the tone and style
communicated from the trailer is just
not what the movie represents at all it
is it is terrible film I can't I can't
even rewatch it I've tried rewatching
and I didn't turn it off I can't say it
doesn't do much of anything it's
again it whirring yeah it's that same
kind of like it's plotting and it's kind
of excruciating like like it's all the
excruciating parts and none of the
rewards and none of the depth that they
kept promising it just kept being like
in a helicopter yeah the helicopter
crash is like a good metaphor for that
movie all right so number one here it is
did you guess it did you guess what the
best trailer is for a terrible film its
x-men origins Wolverine you remember
being excited to see this film in the
theaters I do x-men who the lap-band was
the prior installment in the x-men
franchise and that was a major
disappointment the trailer came out the
reason I like this design because the
x-men trilogy I've been building up a
lot of Wolverines origins they have
animate sent like this was a prequel
that wasn't like we I don't need this
this was like yeah this is cool we can
all finally find out they can renting at
it yeah I will get to see the whole bit
we only got little pieces though there
we heard of William Stryker in part two
you know and then you finally get the
origins trailer and boy does it look
epic fantastic Logan has never been more
buff until futures womanhood and then
this is the toughest who's ever been it
has the Wolverine yell and grunting all
time well they also got like the bone
clauses you have the saber-tooth and
engine-driver has like him as a child
him in wars
after all they're like Civil War stuff
it's like Vietnam wars of universal like
you got the hint of the other comic book
characters gambit was being introduced
in the truth and like why I'm finally
enjoying this movie yeah the trailer
like you know it gives you amped up to
see how they bring into the screen and
Sabretooth is such a popular x-men
villain and then you see that he's going
to be the primary villain here and it's
like oh cool because he was just in Part
1 and he never came back and now he's
going to bother me and then the epic
music with it the visual effects look
good that shot where he's on the
motorcycle and then it gets blown up and
he's jumping towards the helicopter
looked real look like a real stuntman
charging at the helicopter good shot
at least at least again here on the
small screen yeah
and then come to find out none of that
works it's not epic
it is beyond dull and y'all born to
visual effects suck yam it's a
disappointment saber-tooth is one of the
redeeming qualities of the film actually
he was one of the good thing I remember
that movie having a very meandering pace
and sort of like sequence of yeah Ennis
you know and there are times when it
gets down downright wacky it's like when
they do the whole thing we're like the
dude gives of his clothes and he like
ruins their bathroom like in the closet
everyone made a big deal and I try not
to make a big deal of these things like
the claws do look oddly not finished
yeah I know it's strange and so it was a
weird viewing experience I just feel
real bad for Gavin hood when I think
about this movie and then really dining
great sense um you know Ender's Game did
okay okay the work and the thing is to
when we're talking about Wolverine
seeing his origins him as a child him in
these wars and he come to find out
that's all you see is what you see in
the trailer it's just a model I said it
is a montage over the opening credits
you're like you don't get to explore any
of this stuff in but the trailer makes
it look like you're going to get to
really explore all that this trailer
leads with so many things that are just
small interludes of the movies ya know
what is so frustrating is it doesn't hit
any of the actual movie that is inside
of it
yeah the visions are still the best
parts in today yeah other things that
got you looking forward to you know
prequel syndrome stuff even like young
Cyclops which doesn't make sense to me
still yeah because you must be like 45
by the time Scott Summers displays the
chains of our city I've just decided
with the accident of Syria to just you
know always be exhaust on the continuity
you know Ryan Reynolds is Lee it was
like psyched to see how he's gonna do
his Wayne Wilson and that was like his
audition tape and and that was one of
the good things about that movie that
left and got worse that's true but the
thing is a trailer though what this
trailer specific looks huge it makes it
looks huge the thing about this trailer
specifically of why I think this is the
were the best trailer for the best
trailer of them all
the worst list it because it makes it
look like a completely different kind of
film as opposed to it's like yeah I
remember all this stuff from like
Terminator Salvation and quite like I
can still see how the film came out that
we actually saw with origins Wolverine
I'm like this one looks exciting and
entertaining and jam-packed with blood
and explosions of epicness and that is
it's the exact antithesis to that is
just not what this trailer is this
trailer makes it look like a really good
movie this is this Charlie makes it look
like a Wolverine story and the story
about the people he's with along the way
it looks like an emotional around like
like a story about a man's life you know
in a comic book kind of way too because
it does have a comic book feel does feel
broad and expansive it gets you excited
I'm kind of all the levels you want to
be excited or a Wolverine movie admit it
doesn't do that even the touch would
like him at the clock makers who shiny
it's Oh shaggy like oh man this guy knew
them before he had a little hot I knew
you'd back when those were just bones
yeah exactly
well guys when we did this list we're
trying to think of movies that are
universally perceived as bad films you
know there were there were other films
that we we thought about that like firms
that we personally didn't like but we
know that a lot of people do like them
so we didn't put them on the list these
five were really it seemed like every
time we've talked about that these five
always come to mind and yeah like
midnight might not even be the best
examples perhaps but they they always
come to mind for us so we tell you a
good place to get which it causes us to
ask you guys what trailers do you guys
have in mind like put it in the comments
below what are some trailers that you
thought were fantastic but you thought
the film was actually just flat-out
terrible or completely misrepresented
the movie and what you think of our list
maybe people upvote certain ones of them
enough we'll make another one if you can
make another maybe yeah we'll just take
what you guys have to say make our own
video out of it don't give it credit
recurrence do you can subscribe to the
reel rejects click that notification
bell he is dead John Humphrey on Twitter
and Instagram social media manager of
blump house and go check out our patreon
for exclusive perks and rewards having a
total blast over there would love for
you to join the community
check out our t-shirt designs up on
Spreadshirt comm link in the description
box as well good have a happy day